good morning Hank it's Tuesday every
four years the 32 best men's national
soccer teams gather together for the
World Cup which is played in whatever
country has most successfully bribed
FIFA officials it's the most watched
sporting event in the world and the
United States won't be there here's an
introduction to the 32 nations that will
Argentina have Lionel Messi arguably the
best player never to win the World Cup
Australia's national team are called the
soccer ruse which makes them hard to
dislike Belgium have Argyle in their
uniforms so they'll probably win the
tournament Brazil are consistently a joy
to watch except when they are playing
Germany and they're the favourites to
win the World Cup this year Colombia's
jerseys look like they have an armpit
sweat pattern but I will not let that
distract me from the extraordinary good
looks of their star player hummus'
Rodriguez Costa Rica just passed the
United States and life expectancy in
addition to beating us twice in World
Cup qualifying so that's nice for them
Croatia are notable for having a
chessboard on their uniform Denmark
invented Lego so that makes them fun to
root for Egypt has qualified for their
first World Cup since 1990 and they are
led by noted hero and dreamboat Mohamed
Salah and their goalkeeper is 45 years
old which is a real inspiration to old
people like me all in all they are my
adopted team for the World Cup England
right so the deal with England is that
every World Cup all the fans are like
our team isn't even that good we
probably won't even make the
quarterfinals and then they do make the
quarterfinals whereupon they lose and
all the fans are shocked and devastated
that their national team did exactly
what it always does
Francis mascot is a rooster also they're
a trendy pick to win the World Cup this
year but they couldn't beat the United
States and a friendly over the weekend
so I'm a bit dubious Germany are very
good and they have a manager who always
looks like an aging beetle trying to
hail a cab
Iceland qualified for the World Cup
despite having a population smaller than
Wichita Kansas how are we not going to
the World Cup I'm sorry that is off
topic congratulations to Iceland who
would be a great pick for my adopted
team if it weren't for my undying love
for Mohamed Salah Iran's backup
goalkeeper slept on the floor of the
pizza restaurant where he worked until
signing a professional contract a few
years ago almost all of Japan's players
play professionally for Japanese teams
which is why it's no excuse to say MLS
isn't good enough to develop World Cup
level players Mexico are obviously the
best team in North America also they
have Rafa Marquez who will be playing in
his fifth World Cup Morocco have a very
strong defense which they will need a
Spain and Portugal Nigeria meanwhile
have the best kits in the tournament and
if they weren't in the hardest group
they might go far but they are in the
hardest group Panama have qualified for
their first World Cup ever which is
great and I am totally over the fact
that they beat the United States in
qualifying how do you lose to Trinidad
my friend the writer Daniel our tacomas
Peruvian and their uniform has a sash
and they've qualified for their first
World Cup since 1982 making them an
excellent choice for your adopted team
until and unless you look into these
dreamy eyes Poland are a good long shot
picked to go far in the tournament if
their star striker Robert Levin dusky is
informed Portugal have Cristiano Rinaldo
if you're into that kind of thing I'm
sorry I'm trying to work my way through
some of my issues around Real Madrid
right now Russia is hosting the
tournament and I'm not gonna say
anything else because I am genuinely
scared of Vladimir Putin Saudi Arabia
are the biggest underdogs Serbia has a
defense with tons of experience or put
another way they're old nobody agrees
with me but I think Senegal could go to
the semi-finals because Saudi Amane is
really good and know this video has not
been biased by my affection for
Liverpool
South Korea's coach is only four years
older than Egypt's goalkeeper Spain are
kind of the Yankees of soccer Sweden no
longer has football's biggest
personalities Latin ibrahimovic so why
bother
Switzerland specializes in neutrality
which is perhaps why they play so many
excruciating ly boring nil nil draws
Tunisia's kits look so good I bought one
but I fear their World Cup will be brief
and last but not least Uruguay are
probably best known for having a striker
Luis Suarez who has bitten opponents on
three separate occasions but that
ignores the important fact that in more
than 99% of his competitive games Luis
Suarez hasn't bitten anyone a nearly
perfect record I'll be live-tweeting
every game of this year's World Cup at
my sports twitter at sports with John I
hope to see you there
Hank I will see you on Friday